I'm gonna tell you a story from 200
years ago in 1820 French astronomer
Alexis Bouvard almost became the second
person in human history to discover a
planet he had been tracking the position
of Uranus across the night sky using old
star catalogues and it didn't quite go
around the Sun the way that his
predictions said it should sometimes it
was a little too fast sometimes a little
too slow Bouvard knew that his
predictions were perfect so it had to be
that those old star catalogs were bad he
told astronomers of the day do better
measurements so they did astronomers
spent the next two decades meticulously
tracking the position of uranus across
the sky but it still didn't fit Bouvard
x' predictions by 1840 it had become
obvious the problem was not with those
old star catalogs the problem was with
the predictions and astronomers knew why
they realized that there must be a
distant giant planet just beyond the
orbit of Uranus that was tugging along
at that orbit sometimes pulling it along
a little bit too fast sometimes holding
it back what's been frustrating back in
1840 to see these gravitational effects
of this distant giant planet but not yet
know how to actually find it trust me
it's really frustrating there in 1846
another French astronomer urbane levar
ei worked through the math and figured
out how to predict the location of the
planet he sent his prediction to the
Berlin Observatory they opened up their
telescope and in the very first night
they found this faint point of light
slowly moving across the sky and
discovered Neptune it was this close on
the sky Tula very aise predicted
location the story of prediction and
discrepancy and new theory and
triumphant discovery is so classic and
laverra became so famous from it that
people tried to get in on the act
right away in the last hundred and
sixty-three years dozens of astronomers
have used some sort of alleged orbital
discrepancy to predict the existence of
some new planet in the solar system they
have always been wrong the most famous
of these erroneous predictions came from
Percival Lowell who was convinced that
there must be a planet just beyond
Uranus and Neptune messing with those
orbits and so when Pluto was discovered
in 1930 at the Lowell Observatory
everybody assumed that it must be the
planet that Lowell had predicted they
were wrong it turns out Uranus and
Neptune are exactly where they're
supposed to be it took a hundred years
but Bouvard was eventually right
astronomers needed to do better
measurements and when they did those
better measurements it turned out that
Uranus there there is no planet just
beyond the orbit of uranus and neptune
and pluto is thousands of times too
small to have any effect on those orbits
at all so even though planet pluto
turned out not to be the planet it was
originally thought to be it was the
first discovery of what is now known to
be thousands of tiny icy objects in
orbit beyond the planets here you can
see the orbits of Jupiter Saturn Uranus
and Neptune and in that little circle in
the very center is the earth and the Sun
and almost everything that you know and
love and those yellow circles at the
edge are these icy bodies out beyond the
planets these icy bodies are pushed and
pulled by the gravitational fields of
the planets in entirely predictable ways
everything goes around the Sun exactly
the way it is supposed to almost so in
2003 I discovered what was at the time
the most distant known object in the
entire solar system it's hard not to
look at that lonely body out there and
say oh yeah sure so Lowell was wrong
there was no planet just beyond Neptune
but this this could be a new planet the
real question we had was what kind of
orbit does it have around the Sun does
it go in a circle around the Sun like a
plane
it should or is it just a typical member
of this icy belt of bodies that got a
little bit tossed outward and it's now
on its way back in this is precisely the
question that astronomers were trying to
answer about Uranus 200 years ago they
did it by using overlooked observations
of Uranus from 91 years before its
discovery to figure out its entire orbit
we couldn't go quite that far back but
we did find observations of our object
from 13 years earlier that allowed us to
figure out how it went around the Sun so
the question is is it in a circular
orbit around the Sun like a planet or is
it on its way back in like one of these
typical icy bodies and the answer is no
it has a massively elongated orbit that
takes 10,000 years to go around the Sun
we named this object Sedna after the
Inuit goddess of the sea in honor of the
cold icy places where it spends all of
its time we now know that Sedna it's
about 1/3 the size of Pluto and it's a
relatively typical member of those icy
bodies out beyond Neptune relatively
typical except for this bizarre orbit
now you might look at this orb and say
yeah that's bizarre 10,000 years ago
around the Sun but that's not really the
bizarre part the bizarre part is that in
those 10,000 years
Sedna never comes close to anything else
in the solar system even at its closest
approach to the Sun Sedna is further
from Neptune the Neptune is from the
earth if Sedna had had an orbit like
this that kisses the orbit of Neptune
once around the Sun that would have
actually been really easy to explain
that would have just been an object that
had been in a circular orbit around the
Sun in that region of icy bodies had
gotten a little bit too close to Neptune
one time and then got slingshot out and
is now on its way back in but Sedna
never comes close to anything known in
the solar system that could have given
it that slingshot Neptune can't be
responsible but something had to be
responsible this was the first time
since 1845 that we saw the gravitational
effects of something in the outer solar
system
and didn't know what it was I actually
thought I knew what the answer was
sure it could have been some distant
giant planet in the outer solar system
but by this time that idea was so
ridiculous and had been so thoroughly
discredited that I didn't take it very
seriously but 4.5 billion years ago when
when the Sun formed in a cocoon of
hundreds of other stars any one of those
stars could have gotten just a little
bit too close to Sedna and perturbed it
onto the orbit that it has today when
that cluster of stars dissipated into
the galaxy the orbit of Sedna would have
been left as a fossil record of this
earliest history of the Sun I was so
excited by this idea by the idea that we
could look at the fossil history of the
birth of the Sun but I spent the next
decade looking for more objects with
orbits like Sedna in that 10-year period
I found zero but my colleagues Chad
Trujillo and Scott Shepherd did a better
job and they have now found several
objects with orbits like Sedna which is
super exciting but what's even more
interesting is that they found that all
these objects are not only on these
distant elongated orbits they also share
a common value of this obscure orbital
parameter that in celestial mechanics we
call argument of perihelion when they
realized it was clustered an argument
perihelion they immediately jumped up
and down said wow it must be caused by a
distant giant planet out there which is
really exciting except it makes no sense
at all let me try to explain to you why
with an analogy imagine a person walking
down a Plaza and looking 45 degrees to
his right side a lot of reasons I might
happen
super easy to explain no big deal
imagine now many different people all
walking in different directions across
the plaza but all looking 45 degrees to
the direction that they're moving
everybody's moving in different
directions
everybody's looking in different
directions but they're all looking 45
degrees to the direction of motion what
could cause something like that I have
no idea it's very difficult to think of
any reason that that would happen
and this is essentially what that
clustering in argument of perihelion was
telling us scientists were generally
baffled and they assumed it must just be
a fluke and some bad observations they
told the astronomers do better
measurements I actually took a very
careful look at those measurements
though and they were right these objects
really did all share a common value of
argument of perihelion and they
shouldn't something had to be causing
that the final piece of the puzzle came
into place in in 2016 when my colleague
konstantin batygin who works three doors
down from me and i realized that the
reason that everybody was baffled was
because argument of perihelion was only
part of the story if you look at these
objects the right way they're all
actually lined up in space in the same
direction and they're all tilted in
space in the same direction it's as if
all those people on the plaza are all
walking in the same direction and
they're all looking 45 degrees to the
right side that's easy to explain
they're all looking at something these
objects in the outer solar system are
all reacting to something but what
Constantine and I spent a year trying to
come up with any explanation other than
a distant giant planet in the outer
solar system we did not want to be the
33rd and 34th people in history to
propose this planet to yet again be told
we were wrong but after a year there was
really no choice we could come up with
no other explanation other that then
that there is a distant massive planet
on an elongated orbit inclined to the
rest of the solar system that is forcing
these patterns for these objects in the
outer solar system guess what else a
planet like this does remember that
strange orbit of Sedna how it was kind
of pulled away from the Sun in one
direction a planet like this would make
orbits like that all day long
we knew we were on to something so this
brings us to today we are basically 1845
Paris
we see the effects of the gravitational
effects of a distant giant planet and we
are trying to work out the calculations
to tell us where to look
to point our telescopes to find this
planet we've done massive Suites of
computer simulations massive amounts of
analytic calculations and here's what I
can tell you so far
first this planet which we call Planet 9
because because that's what it is
Planet 9 is six times the mass of the
earth this is no slightly smaller than
Pluto let's all argue about whether it's
a planet or not thing this is the fifth
largest planet in our entire solar
system for context let me show you the
sizes of the planets in the back there
you can see the massive Jupiter and
Saturn next to them a little bit smaller
Uranus and Neptune up in the corner the
terrestrial planets Mercury Venus Earth
and Mars you can even see that belt of
icy bodies beyond Neptune of which Pluto
is a member
good luck bringing around which one it
is and here is planet nine planet nine
is big planet nine so big you should
probably wonder why haven't we found it
yet well plenty 9 is big but it's also
really really far away it's something
like 15 times further away than Neptune
and that makes it about 50,000 times
fainter than Neptune and also the sky is
a really big place we've narrowed down
where we think it is to a relatively
small area of the sky but it would still
take us years to systematically cover
that area the sky with the large
telescopes that we need to see something
that's this far away and this faint
luckily we might not have to
just like Bouvard used unrecognized
observations of uranus from 91 years
before its discovery I bet that there
are unrecognized images that show the
location of Planet 9 it's going to be a
massive computational undertaking to go
through all of the old data and pick out
that one faint moving planet but we're
underway and I think we're getting close
so I would say get ready we are not go
to match the very A's make a prediction
have the planet found in a single night
that close to where your predicted it
record but I do bet that within the next
couple of years some astronomer
somewhere will find a faint point of
light slowly moving off cross the sky
and triumphantly announced the discovery
of a new and quite possibly not the last
real planet of our solar system thank
you
[Applause]